welcome everyone it gives me great
pleasure to invite you all on behalf of
the Terry lectureship committee to dis
faults Terry lectures in the true spirit
of the request to promote and foster
assimilation and interpretation building
upon the truths of science and
philosophy our speakers this year are
Joel Premack and Nancy Ellen Abrams who
will be talking to us broadly on the
cultural context of cosmology and will
offer insights into our place in the
cosmos what is unique about this year's
Terry lectures is that for the first
time we have two lecturers who happen to
be a husband and wife team comprising of
a scientist and a philosopher engaged in
a very vibrant innovative and creative
collaboration Joel Premack is professor
of physics at the University of
California at Santa Cruz he has been at
the forefront of research in the
formation and evolution of galaxies and
the nature of dark matter that makes up
most of the mass in the universe
starting out as a particle theorist
having made fundamental contributions to
what is now called the Standard Model of
particle physics professor Premack began
working in cosmology and became a leader
in the new field of particle
astrophysics he is one of the original
proposers of the theory of cold dark
matter which has become the basis for
the standard and modern picture of
structure formation in the universe
aside from his scientific contributions
joel has had an abiding interest in
science policy in particular on the
issue of nuclear disarmament he has
co-authored an influential book titled
advice and dissent with Frank Warren
hippo he was instrumental in setting up
the congressional science Fellows
Program Joel and Nancy were also part of
the official American delegation to
Moscow that helped negotiate the
decommissioning of nuclear reactors in
space with the former USSR Nancy
Abraham's read history and philosophy is
an undergraduate followed by a law
degree and further qualification in
international law finding the practice
of law to be somewhat restrictive Nancy
moved into the arena of science policy
she has long been interested in the role
of science
shaping politics and has worked for the
Ford Foundation and the US Congress's
office of Technology Assessment she
helped develop a novel procedure
scientific mediation to help government
agencies make wise policy decisions in
areas where the relevant science is
crucial yet rather uncertain or
controversial also interested in science
board sciences border with myth Nancy
Abrams has worked as a scholar to place
the discoveries of modern cosmology into
a cultural context and as a writer and
songwriter to communicate their possible
meanings at a deeper level the 2010
Terry lectures will also for the first
time be a multimedia presentation unlike
anything we've seen before including
visually stunning astronomical videos
based on real observations and
cutting-edge simulations of the
invisible universe from Joel's group set
to Nancy's music these calculations have
been performed with the state-of-the-art
supercomputing facilities in today's
first lecture titled the new universe
Nancy and Joe will explain the profound
role of a shared scientific
understanding of the universe with a
strong sense of our place in it we look
forward eagerly to this journey before
we start I would like to request all of
you to turn off your cell phones or
beepers thank you very much for that
thank you very much Priya that was
certainly one of the most eloquent
introductions we've had and certainly
the most stunningly well-dressed well
welcome everyone to this series of
lectures cosmic society and the first
talk which is the new universe in this
series of lectures we're going to do two
major things and they're going to be
intertwined the first is that will
present the new scientific picture of
the universe as visually as possible and
the second is that will interpret what
the discovery of this astonishing new
picture of the universe may mean for our
lives and discuss how it could help the
Earth's peoples become a cosmic society
that is a society whose members have
come to terms with their place in a
dynamic evolving universe and are
capable of thinking in and acting for
the very long term every culture that
anthropologists have studied has had a
cosmology meaning a story of how the
world began how humans came to exist and
the role of invisible forces in these
events usually spirits ancestors or gods
of course their notions of the universe
were not what anyone today would
consider scientifically accurate but
with what we've gained in this
scientific age we've also lost something
important we may be the first major
culture in human history to have no
coherent idea what our universe looks
like or how to think about how we fit
into the big picture in those high
places of human consciousness where
cosmic mythologies carried our ancestors
there is for our high-tech fast-paced
world just narrative darkness many
religious people still believe that
earth was created as is a few thousand
years ago while many scientifically
educated people think that Earth is just
a lonely rock in trackless space whose
right neither one both pictures are
wrong meanwhile our global problems are
accelerating religiously just
to fight violence exhaustion of
planetary resources global overheating
economic chaos etc in these lectures
we're going to suggest that there's a
connection between our lack of a shared
cosmology and our increase in global
problems very few people realize this
because in modern life astronomy seems
to have very little relevance people
think of astronomical discoveries as
fodder for a news article that's fun to
skim perhaps or a great topic for five
minutes of dinner party banter but
frankly there's just no widely
understood connection between what's
happening in distant space and us right
here but the new cosmology actually
makes it possible at last to understand
how the universe fits together on all
size scales including our own the joke
among scientists used to be that
cosmology is the science where the ratio
of theory to data is nearly infinite
lots of theories almost no data but in
the last two decades this ratio has
completely flipped a flood of new data
has eliminated every theory but one and
that one not only fits all the data
increasingly it's predicting the results
of observations before the data comes in
the more we understand the theory the
better it fits the rapidly accumulating
data the technical name for this theory
is lambda CDM lambda for dark energy and
CDM for cold dark matter it tells us
that everything we can see with the
greatest telescopes on an orbiting Earth
is only half of one percent of what's
really out there the stars the glowing
gas clouds and this is one of the
pictures that just came down from Hubble
Space Telescope with the new camera wide
field camera 3 this shows the glowing
gas cloud in Carina in optical and
ultraviolet
and this shows exactly the same thing
but now in infrared and other capability
of this new camera so you can see
through the dust that was obscuring
where new stars are forming so that and
also this wonderful new picture again
with wide field camera 3 of a planetary
nebula this picture of the planets
Saturn taken out near Saturn by the
Cassini spacecraft this actually shows
two planets I hope you can see there's
earth seeing through Saturn's rings so
all of these pictures and also this
wonderful picture of the Hubble Ultra
Deep Field showing many many galaxies
out to the cosmic horizon all of these
images represent just half a percent of
what's actually there the universe as a
whole is controlled by two invisible
things whose tangle with each other has
created the galaxies and which are the
only the galaxies which are the only
home for the evolution of star systems
in life the two invisible substances are
dark matter and dark energy and it's
those together that are the basis of
this modern theory of how the universe
works and how it evolved the double dark
Theory dark matter and dark energy were
unknown and even unimaginative century
with dark matter collapsing the galaxies
into being and dark energy accelerating
them apart the evolving universe is
turned out to be far more dynamic than
the idea of empty space scattered with
stars and planets the end of the 20th
century in the beginning of the 21st has
been a golden age of astronomy and in
particular cosmology in a very real
sense we have discovered the universe
what is emerging from modern cosmology
is the first story of the nature and
origin of the universe that might
actually be true
the difference between our new
scientific picture and all earlier
creation stories is that the modern
scientific story is supported by an
immense amount of evidence what's more
this is the first cosmology ever created
by collaboration of peoples from
different religions races and cultures
all around the world all of whose
contributions are subjected to the same
standards of verifiability the new
universe excludes no one and sees all
humans is equal there is a revolution in
scientific cosmology happening now that
may open the door to a believable
picture of the larger reality in which
earth our lives and all of our religions
are embedded this picture of the
universe could become the foundation of
a cosmic society now what exactly is a
picture of the universe here's an
example from ancient Egypt let's
simplify that just a little bit in this
picture the earth is flat and it's a god
named Gabe the heavens is his sister and
lover the goddess Newt they were born
locked together in an embrace and were
separated by the god shoe their father
who represented the air they longed to
come together again but she would hold
them apart and thus maintain the
creation only as long as the Egyptians
perform their rituals properly so
Egyptians felt that they were upholding
the cosmos literally and major spiritual
and ethical implications followed they
understood the everyday world as being
embedded within an awe-inspiring but
mostly invisible spiritual cosmos the
Nile for example flowed from the
spiritual world onto farms the lives of
the spiritual beings gave meaning to
life here the ancient Egyptians had a
rich and satisfying explanation of life
nature and the gods even though the
nature part was far from accurate by
modern standards now much later in
ancient Israel and Judah the three-part
flat earth cosmos was still unquestioned
but the parts were no longer God's
as you can see but now they were
inanimate earth air and firmament for
the Hebrews there could be only one God
but then came the first great
cosmological shift it occurred when the
ancient Greek imagination burst out of
this effectively two dimensional flat
land earth of Genesis to the three
dimensional universe the Greeks realized
that Earth is not a pancake but a sphere
now by the Middle Ages educated people
from the Middle East and North Africa
across Europe all the way to Scandinavia
had come to believe that earth was a
sphere at the center of a spherical
universe everything revolved around the
earth nested crystal spheres carried the
moving planets and the outermost sphere
carried all the fixed stars the whole
universe rotated around Earth once a day
and outside the sphere of the stars was
heaven God had placed the spheres
exactly where they belonged in a great
chain of being and the place of every
creature and institution on the earth
was part of this downward continuation
of a cosmic hierarchy thus it was
considered blasphemous to question the
hierarchy or the place God had chosen in
it for you this cosmology both explained
and enforced the social rigidity of the
medieval world but although it was wrong
astronomically that earth is the center
of the universe it was right
psychologically the universe must be
viewed from the inside from our Center
where we really are and not from some
perspective on the periphery or outside
in the medieval picture just as in the
egyptian picture the whole physical
world was surrounded by a spiritual
cosmos whose doings gave meaning to what
was going on here the second great
cosmological shift was the Copernican
revolution which began when Kaepernick
is proposed in 1543 that if the Sun
rather than the earth were seen as
central it would be easier to understand
the motions of the planets Galileo
Kepler and Newton completed the job
and the medieval picture of the universe
was replaced by what we now refer to as
the Newtonian picture in the Newtonian
picture earth is not the center of the
universe but moves like the other
planets orbiting our star the Sun in a
universe where no place is special or
central least of all ours this
intriguing drawing by Escher really gets
across the idea of space as an endless
grid where no place is any different
from any other there was no longer a
place where the physical became the
spiritual it was now physical all the
way out possibly to infinity this is the
universe that the great novelist D H
Lawrence once described as a dreary on
and on without any meaning with the
Newtonian picture of physical reality
dominant around them religious people
have often felt faced with a choice deny
the validity of science or accept it but
believe that there are two kinds of
reality the spiritual and the physical
with spiritual reality not constrained
by the laws of physics unfortunately in
such a dualistic reality it becomes
possible to believe in science and still
believe in almost anything else well we
who are alive today have an
extraordinary opportunity which as you
can see has only arisen twice before in
the history of Western civilization and
that's the opportunity to see reality of
fresh through a new picture of the
universe we are the first humans
privileged to see a face of the universe
that no earlier culture ever imagined
religious cosmologies like those of
Egypt and the Middle Ages may not have
been factually correct but they offered
guidance about how to live with a
feeling of belonging in the world modern
scientific cosmology says nothing about
human beings or how we should live or
feel it aims to provide scientific
accuracy not meaning or guidance but
today we really can't afford to see
these as separate anymore the human race
needs a believable picture of the
universe that includes all of us we need
to connect the two
different understandings of cosmology
into a science-based appreciation of our
human place in the modern universe let's
get oriented in the universe what is our
cosmic address this is a map of our
local neighborhood on progressively
larger scales it shows our so to speak
geographic place in the universe we're
going to use this to orient ourselves
first at the top our solar system where
we live on the third Rock from the Sun
earth each of the large shaded v's shows
how the entire picture above is just a
tiny point in the much larger scale
picture immediately below so our solar
system is about halfway out in the Milky
Way galaxy it takes light about a day to
cross the entire solar system but it
takes light a hundred thousand years to
cross the visible part of the Milky Way
the Milky Way in turn is just a dot on
the scale of the local supercluster of
galaxies down here it's out here in the
boondocks in the video i'm about to show
we're going to go on a virtual voyage
from Earth past the local stars out of
the disk of the Milky Way and then
across our local supercluster to the
Virgo cluster of galaxies at its center
the Virgo cluster is the densest
concentration of galaxies for a hundred
million light-years around the stars
that you'll see at the beginning of this
video were mapped a little over 10 years
ago and the computer lets us move
through the stars and the telescopic
images of nearby objects we're going to
start facing this familiar constellation
Orion the Milky Way arcs to the left of
Orion as we fly toward the sword hanging
below Orion's belt
the sword comes apart because all the
stars making up the sword or a different
distances we see that the center of the
sword is the Orion Nebula a gas cloud
illuminated by the young stars forming
there now as we pass the Horsehead
Nebula were 1,500 light-years from Earth
the next glowing gas cloud that we see
is another stellar nursery the rosette
nebula
but not all these glowing nebulae are
stellar birth places this is a place
where a star died it was seen on earth
about a thousand years ago this is the
remnant of the crab supernova and you
can see the neutron star dat Center
blinking 30 times a second until now
we've been inside the disk of the Milky
Way where our view of the center is
blocked by dust created by explosions
like the Crab Nebula so let's rise up
and out of the disk so that we can see
the magnificent panorama of a galaxy
like our own as the galaxy recedes into
the distance with the large and small
Magellanic Clouds and other satellite
galaxies everything we see now is a
galaxy
what's now come into view is the great
galaxy in Andromeda and in the
foreground a smaller spiral galaxy
triangulum where m33 as we go through
this glowing gas cloud in m33 where 2
million light years from home our goal
in this voyage is the Virgo cluster just
coming into view on the left but we're
going to take a scenic route pass some
of the prettiest nearby galaxies that
can be seen with an amateur telescope
now I hope you can see that there's a
chain of galaxies that ends here at the
Virgo cluster and in fact there are
several such chains of galaxies that
meet at the Virgo cluster we're entering
this chain here in the Ursa Major group
of galaxies we're going to ride down it
toward the Virgo cluster before we were
seeing largely spiral galaxies but now
we're starting to see big balls of stars
elliptical galaxies this voyage ends at
this large elliptical galaxy at the
center of the Virgo cluster m87
astronomers call it there's a jet coming
out of the center and in the center
there's a gigantic black hole with a
mass three billion times the mass of our
Sun fast as it is the local supercluster
is just a tiny patch of the universe
there are many sighs skills in the
universe from bigger than galaxies to
trees and people to bacteria to atoms
and beyond how can we grasp them all we
hope that this graph will help and I'll
try to help you understand it by going
through it piece by piece first of all
remember that 10 to the 10 is one
followed by 10 zeros that's 10 billion
and 10 to the minus 10 is a 10 billion
each of the tick marks on both axes are
separated by 10 billion by factor of 10
billion this is sighs this is mass or
energy one of sciences most essential
tasks is to rule out the impossible the
two slope lines represent the borders of
the possible
first the upper line is dictated by
Einstein's theory of gravity called
general relativity the relativity line
tells you for whatever size you choose
on the x-axis the maximum mass on the
y-axis that could possibly be packed
into it for example here is a neutron
star it's formed when at the end of its
life a massive star collapses a slightly
more violent collapse contracts that
neutron star so that it crosses the red
line and then it collapses a way to know
sighs at all according to general
relativity a black hole so general
relativity excludes this entire part of
the diagram the lower line in blue is
dictated by quantum mechanics the
uncertainty principle tells us that in
order to probe objects on smaller and
smaller scales more and more energy is
required represented by the vertical
axis of the diagram mass or energy
related by e equals MC squared thus the
region to the left of the white wedge of
material reality is excluded that means
that there's a smallest mass sorry a
smallest length is what I meant to say
we can't conceptualize anything smaller
than the Planck length and our current
understanding of physics and here's why
the smaller the region the more energy
is required to locate something in it to
locate anything in a plank size region
requires so much energy that the region
collapses into a black hole which would
instantly evaporate by Hawking radiation
and so the smallest size theoretically
possible is the plank size about 10 to
the minus 33 centimeters it always helps
to know where humans fit in in the
middle of the diagram is the human scale
about a metre high or demeter
and about 10 to the 5th grams about 100
kilograms and be a little bit less for
most of us the entire visible universe
is surrounded by our cosmic horizon so
that's the largest size that we can see
every place in the universe is the
center of its own cosmic horizon which
is determined by the age and expansion
history of the universe beyond the
cosmic horizon space is likely to be the
same as nearby with galaxies filled with
stars like our own but there's no way we
can know for sure because we can't
receive any direct information about
things beyond the horizon light cannot
reach us from any region out there now
that voyage that we took to the Virgo
cluster spanned a distance of about 60
million light-years which is about 10 to
the 25th centimeters right here on this
diagram well not only is there a largest
and a smallest possible size but it
turns out that they may be connected so
let's lay a serpent along the x axis of
the wedge of material reality and we put
the tip of the tail of the serpent at
the Planck length and its head at the
cosmic horizon and now the serpent
represents all the possible size scales
in the visible universe but the serpent
it turns out is not lying flat like an
x-axis it's actually swallowing its tail
so we call this the cosmic or Boris or a
Boris is a Greek word for tail
swallowing the cosmic or Boris
represents the universe as a continuity
of vastly different size scales about 60
orders of magnitude separate the very
smallest the Planck length from the very
largest there's the Planck length and
the cosmic horizon at the head of the
serpent now note that the human scale
is right in the middle so traveling
clockwise around the serpent from head
to tail we move down from the cosmic
horizon to the size of a supercluster of
galaxies size of a galaxy the distance
to the Orion Nebula the size of the
solar system the Sun the earth a
mountain course we're there in the
middle and aunt a single bacterium a DNA
molecule and Adam and the nucleus of an
atom the scale beyond that of the weak
interactions which are carried by the W
and Z particles and approaching the tail
the extremely small size scales on which
physicists hope to find massive dark
matter that's what the DM stands for and
I've even smaller sizes a grand unified
theory that's the GU T at the top the
concept of size scales is very useful
not only for visualizing the universe
but for understanding ethics and
spirituality for our time but will
return to this the cosmic serpent
swallowing its tail which is a image due
to Sheldon Glashow the Nobel Prize
winner Harvard this represents the
possibility that gravity links the
largest and smallest scales and thereby
unifies the universe this actually
happens in superstring theory a
mathematically beautiful idea that
remains our best hope for a theory that
could unify quantum physics and
relativity in string theory sizes
smaller than the Planck length get
remapped in two sizes larger than the
Planck length so there's a connection
between the smallest and the largest on
different size scales different physical
forces control what happens everything
has to be the size it is it could never
work if there were any substantial
difference in size scale models don't
work like the real thing size matters so
on large scales gravity controls on the
size scales between mountains and atoms
it's the electromagnetic forces
electricity magnetism the basis of
chemistry
on the size scale of the atomic nucleus
it's the weak and strong interactions
that control along with electromagnetism
now we physicists have a very good
theory that fits all the data from
accelerators that includes the weak
strong and electromagnetic interactions
this is the so-called Standard Model of
particle physics but there's no room in
the standard model for most of the mass
in the universe Dark Matter so we think
that Dark Matter must correspond to
forces on scales smaller than the ones
we've talked about so far so dark matter
and then as I mentioned super strings
size matters this idea that size matters
was perhaps first understood by Galileo
and this illustration is from his last
book discourses and two new sciences
which he wrote under house arrest
Galileo explained that no animal could
be three times its normal height and
stayed the same shape simply scaled up
if the height increases by a factor of
three the strength of the bones if
they're if they retain the same shape
would just be proportional to their
cross-sectional area which would be
three times three or nine times stronger
but the weight of the animal would
increase with its volume and so it would
be 27 times greater and the bones only
nine times stronger could not support
the weight of such a heavy animal that's
why an elephant can't look like a large
gazelle the bones have to be much
thicker in proportion to their length do
you suppose Hollywood understands that
and here's another example now shrinking
smaller everything has to be the size it
is or it doesn't work right these
familiar films illustrate the popular
misunderstanding that things work the
same way no matter how much bigger or
smaller than normal they are so what's
our place we humans are exactly or
almost exactly at the center of all
possible sizes and this is true here we
are whether the units used are
centimeters nanometers or light years so
it's not an anthropocentric bias
if we use different units the only
difference is the numbers in the
exponents we would still be Central and
we couldn't be anywhere else if we were
much smaller we wouldn't be made of
enough atoms to have the kind of complex
consciousness that we have if we were
much larger the speed of thought and
other internal communications which are
ultimately limited by the speed of light
would be too slow it's really only near
the center of possible sizes that
consciousness like ours can arise and
this tells us something about
intelligent aliens if they exist because
anywhere in the universe they'll have to
be approximately our size now that
doesn't mean five or six feet tall that
means somewhere between a redwood tree
and a puppy that's actually a very
narrow sliver of possibilities so here
we are at the center of the cosmocorps
Oh Boris and the size scales surrounding
us make up our conscious world which
we've attempted to show here in sunlight
it includes everything from the littlest
creatures that humans can see with the
naked eye smaller than an sprats and
adds up to about the size of the sun and
this section is what most people think
of as reality but as you can see it's
not all of reality it's just a very
special part of the universe for which
we humans have awareness and intuition
this is our homeland in the universe so
Joel and I decided that we would give a
name to this very special group of size
skills and we call it Midgard in the Old
Norse cosmology Midgard was the human
world it was an island representing
stability and civilized society in the
middle of the world see which was the
Norse universe the world see was large
and there was room in it not only for
Midgard but for the land of the giants
and the land of the gods this is an
excellent description metaphorically of
course of Midgard in the expanding
universe our Midgard is the island of
size scales that are familiar and
comprehensible to human beings but
beyond the shores of Midgard in one
direction outward into
expanding world see is the land of
incomprehensibly giant beings like black
holes a million times the mass of the
Sun or galaxies made of hundreds of
billions of stars in the other direction
from Midgard inward toward the small
lies a living cellular world and beyond
that the quantum world and these micro
lands are the evolutionary and physical
sources of everything we are that may
not make them gods but compared to us
they're more prolific more ancient
Universal and omnipresent like the
North's Midgard our Midgard is not
isolated from these other lands in the
world see it's connected as the cosmic
Ouroboros illustrates Midgard is
everywhere in the universe it's not a
place it's actually a setting of the
intellectual zoom lens so if you travel
to a planet for example in a distant
galaxy a billion light-years away and
tried to get around your mid garden
tuition would be very useful although of
course fallible but if you stay right
here in this room and just change your
mental focus to think about size scales
outside Midgard in either direction
large or small you find that your
intuition becomes worthless without
science no one can and no one ever did
imagine accurately how very small or
very large things actually behave until
the 20th century infinity was thought of
as an endless extension of Midgard
that's the way Isaac Newton pictured the
universe but now we know that once you
jump off the island of Midgard nothing
is the same the very laws of physics
that control events change with
exponential increases or decreases in
size scale physicists may think that the
word physical means anything described
by the laws of physics but to most
people physical means solid observable
unquestionably here physical is
intuitive concept not a scientific one
only in Midgard do object satisfy
people's intuitive sense of what's
physical why does this matter because
many people assume
the spiritual reality exists as Nancy
said earlier it is separate from the
physical universe it transcends the
universe and therefore does not obey the
laws of physics at least it doesn't have
to but the concept of Midgard undermines
this belief not by telling us anything
about the spiritual but by making
clearer what the word physical means to
most people the largest structures
inside the cosmic horizon superclusters
of galaxies are actually expanding apart
faster and faster and in billions of
years they'll disperse they're not bound
together by gravity but by r dot
connecting Minds so in some sense
they're not really physical objects in
the opposite direction of Midgard toward
the very small there are elementary
particles that are not particles like
marbles but rather quantum mechanical
objects that are routinely in two or
more places at once the strange truth is
that what we usually think of as
physical is a property of Midgard
perhaps the defining property unless
Midgard is what most people think of as
physical beyond Midgard however lies
most of the cosmic Ouroboros most of the
physical universe much of it is not
physical in the common sense meaning of
the word but it is nevertheless real and
governed by the laws of physics
transcendence is not some kind of jump
to a reality beyond the universe as if
that even meant anything transcendence
is what happens within our universe
every few powers of ten for example on
the atomic and the subatomic scales
human means nothing there's no humanists
to our atoms whether atoms are inside us
inside a rock or drifting through space
it's all the same to them we conscious
beings understand that atomic behavior
is fundamental to what we are but on the
atomic size scale even inside our own
bodies we as we think of ourselves we do
not exist a human being transcends the
world of atomic interactions we are
qualitatively completely different
although completely consistent each size
scale is in seamless continuity with the
next and yet every few powers of ten
WHAM there's a qualitative difference a
new phenomenon like temperature or
consciousness
comes into being or hitherto irrelevant
law of physics takes control choppiness
in the way complexity grows is
characteristic of the entire cosmic
Ouroboros and so qualitative change
every few powers of ten is a universal
pattern as the physicist Phil Anderson
says more is different so let's take a
fast trip now through all the size
scales that it's possible to visualize
from bigger than superclusters down to
the size of smaller than the atomic
nucleus and notice that there is going
to be an arrow pointing to the size
scale on the cosmic aura Boris that
you're seeing at that moment
good Ouroboros thinking give us a new
way of understanding ourselves
exponential growth happens not only in
sizes but also in the complexity of
human interactions everyone has probably
noticed that although individuals can be
kind generous and wise people
collectively in the form of a committee
a city or a country are almost never
kind generous or wise even though the
individuals who make up those groups may
be a recent newspaper headline I saw
said do the banks have no shame no banks
can't have shame a collective cannot in
principle feel or act like a human being
because it's not human even though it's
made of humans this may be hard to
believe at first but think of it this
way you are all made of elementary
particles but you don't behave anything
like an elementary particle remember you
transcend them we humans are the most
complicated things we know of in the
universe every one of us has multiple
roles on all these size scales we have
our own self-consciousness we have an
identity as part of a family as part of
our tribe or community part of our
religion or nationality part of the
human species life earth and we are also
part of the self consciousness of the
cosmos our sense of identity of who and
what we truly are expands breathtakingly
the moment we realize that we are all
these things with our new understanding
of the cosmic or Boris that different
laws control events on different size
scales we can begin to bring our
consciousness of our full selves our
potential and our responsibilities into
harmony with universal reality the left
side of this human identity or
Morris represents the traditional layers
of consciousness that we humans have
developed through cultural evolution but
we're not finished you will notice a gap
between the religious and nationalistic
identities on the one hand and species
identity on the other how can we get
across this gap how will we jump from
traditional narrow identities that are
endlessly in conflict with each other to
a science-based identity that tells us
that it's far more important that we are
human beings then that we are part of
any smaller subgroup modern biology has
discovered that all humans are more
closely related to each other
genetically then are the members of any
other species on the planet in
scientific cosmology the challenge is to
move out of Midgard but for expanding
our human identity the challenge is to
move into this central area because it
represents the crossover from subspecies
identity two species identity from
traditional religious cosmologies to a
science-based appreciation of our true
place in the universe the jump two
species identity is a qualitative jump
of course we have to keep expanding our
consciousness to recognize our even
larger identities as the consciousness
of Earth and the cosmos but these will
follow much more easily once we have
accepted that we humans are all in this
together in the Bible Jacob has a dream
in which there's a ladder from Earth to
heaven and angels are moving up and down
the ladder and here are two beautiful
traditional interpretations of that idea
by William Blake and Marc Chagall but in
the modern universe the real Jacob's
Ladder is the cosmic or a Boris and the
angels going up and down are our own
educated consciousnesses each of us can
play all of our roles only if we adjust
our consciousness to think in the
appropriate way on each size scale that
is if we move up and down the ladder
this may sound obvious but it is
anything but
most people are still thinking about
global politics or economics with
understandings moral judgements and
above all a sense of time that are
appropriate only two much smaller size
scales like a family or community a year
a single lifetime they have no way of
comprehending the thousands or even tens
of thousands of years that things we are
doing to our planet might last the
oceans are already destined to rise for
a thousand years because of global
warming even if human beings all around
the world completely stop putting
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
tomorrow radioactive waste could be
dangerous for a hundred thousand years
extinction is four ever the science of
cosmology aims only to understand the
underlying principles and the history of
the universe not to change people's
lives and not to challenge their
religions but once we find out about
these principles they necessarily change
our thinking we realize that we are
governed by them and so is everything
that's what Universal truly means a
cosmic society needs a cosmology that's
based on science but gives us some
guidance about how to live every
traditional ethical system teaches how
to get along with other individuals in
the tribe but now modern leaders both
political and corporate control events
on enormous time and size scales that no
religious political or other tradition
has ever even contemplated big changes
in ethics are required for decisions on
these scales the principle of the cosmic
or Oh Boris could help us understand how
groups of us can collaborate
respectfully and productively with
outside groups on all relevant size
scales no religion teaches how to do
this at least not yet there are
invaluable benefits available to people
who claim they're accurate and rightful
place in the universe and adjust their
thinking accordingly to feel your roots
stretching back through cosmic time is
to know who you are
and to see from a cosmic perspective
these are two abilities that our species
needs to cultivate far more widely if we
want to protect the chances for our
descendants over the cosmologically long
time in lectures three and four next
week we will come to the question of how
to live in the new universe the answer
will be based not only on the new
understanding of size but on the
subjects we're going to cover in the
next lectures the nature of time what
the universe is mostly made of how it
began how we came to be here and how we
can create stories about these things
that are powerful and bonding as well as
accurate science is the foundation but
discovering and expressing its mythic
meaning will be essential if it's going
to have any real impact on our lives we
created cosmic society not by zipping
around the cosmos that by expanding our
thinking right here in the lecture
tomorrow we will concentrate on the rear
stuff we humans are made of compared to
the rest of the universe and the role of
time and letting these ingredients
interact one of the main things that we
hope to explain is that we're special or
central in fundamental ways our bodies
are midway between the largest and
smallest possible sizes we are made of
the rarest material in the universe
heavy elements Stardust here's some
Stardust that's a type 1a supernova
explosion we like all observers are at
the center of our visible universe and
in the third lecture we'll explain that
we're living at the midpoint of time in
four different senses we hope to see you
back tomorrow for lecture 2 and let me
tell you that if you enjoyed the videos
this lecture you have a real treat
coming next lecture there are I think
eight major videos in next lecture thank
you